MORNING, THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE WILL BE IN ORDER.
UH, LET'S FIRST ESTABLISH A
QUORUM OF THE CONSULTANT. CAL.
THE ROLL, PLEASE. SENATORS
PADILLA THE DEAR PRESENT GROVE.
ALVARADO GILL. ARDO GILL HERE,
CORTEZ CORTEZ HERE, HURTADO.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THERE ARE THREE FILE ITEMS ON
THE DOCKET. FOR TODAY. ITEMS ONE
AND TWO ARE PROPOSED, UH, FOR
CONSENT. THAT OBJECTION. I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. AND CALENDAR
HAS BEEN MOVED. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM ONE
S¼, B, 117 AND FILE ITEM TWO S¼
B 1086. SENATORS PADILLA PAD I,
GROVE ALVARADO GILL. ALVARADO
GAIL EYE, CORTEZ CORTEZ. I
HURTADO. THANK YOU. CONSENT
CALENDAR IS MOVED OUT. UH, FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE IS S¼ B 1367
BY HURTADO TO BE PRESENTED BY
SENATOR ALVARADO GILL.
GOOD MORNING, SENATOR. THANK
YOU, MR CHAIR. UH, MAY I INVITE
MY WITNESS FORWARD AS WELL?
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. I WILL BE PRESENTING
SENATE BILL 1367 ON BEHALF OF
CHAIR TOO. UM THIS BILL SEEKS TO
SAFEGUARD FUNDING FOR THE SAFE
ANIMAL FEED EDUCATION OR SAFE
PROGRAM BY EXTENDING THE SUNSET
ON THE TONNAGE ASSESSMENT FOR
COMMERCIAL FEED FROM JANUARY 1ST
2025 TO JANUARY 1ST 2031. IN
2004, THE ASSEMBLY BILL 1071 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATTHEWS
EXPANDED THE USE OF FUNDS FROM
THE TONNAGE ASSESSMENT TO
INCLUDE RESEARCH AND EDUCATIONAL
OBJECTIVES. THESE RESEARCH AND
EDUCATIONAL GOALS ARE ACHIEVED
THROUGH THE èC Dð FA SAFE
PROGRAM FOR FEED HANDLERS AND
MILLS. THE SAFE PROGRAM PROVIDES
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES TRAINING
PROGRAMS, OUTREACH AND RESEARCH
GRANT OPPORTUNITIES WITHOUT
LEGISLATIVE ACTION. STATUTORY
AUTHORITY FOR THE COMMERCIAL
FEED TONNAGE ASSESSMENT WILL
SUNSET ON JANUARY 1ST 2025. IF
THE SUNSET IS NOT EXTENDED, THE
FUNDS ALLOCATED FOR THE SAFE
PROGRAM WILL CEASE AS THE
TONNAGE ASSESSMENT IS THE ONLY
FUNDING SOURCE FOR THIS PROGRAM.
THE PASSAGE OF SENATE BILL 1367
WOULD ALLOW FOR FURTHER
PROTECTION OF THE SAFE PROGRAM
AND CONTINUE THE UNIQUE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN SAFE THE
COMMERCIAL FEED INDUSTRY AND
RESEARCHERS. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL 1367 IS
ANNALEE AUGUSTINE, REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA GRADE AND FEED
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS ANNALEE
AUGUSTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GRAIN AND FEED
ASSOCIATION. WE REPRESENT
PRODUCERS OF FEED AND NUTRIENTS
FOR CALIFORNIA'S LIVESTOCK
FARMERS AND COMPANION PET OWNERS
. WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR S¼ B
1367, WHICH EXTENDS THE
AUTHORITY FOR THE SECRETARY OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE TO
DESIGNATE FUNDING OBTAINED
THROUGH A TAX ON COMMERCIAL FEED
FOR RESEARCH AND EDUCATION, THIS
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION TOWARD
THE SAFE ANIMAL AND FEED
EDUCATION PROGRAM COMMONLY KNOWN
AS THE SAFE PROGRAM. THIS
PROGRAM PROVIDES EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES TRAINING PROGRAMS,
OUTREACH RESEARCH AND GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP CALIFORNIA
COMMERCIAL FEED INDUSTRY ENSURE
THE SAFE MANUFACTURER AND USE OF
COMMERCIAL FEED. SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES INCLUDE VOLUNTARY
REVIEWS OF LABELS, INDUSTRY
WORKSHOPS AND FOOD SAFETY PLAN
CONSULTATIONS. THE SAFE PROGRAM
PROMOTES GOOD MANUFACTURING.
SAYS WHICH HAS BECOME
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT AS THE
AMOUNT AND DIVERSITY OF ANIMAL
FEED COMMODITIES USED IN
CALIFORNIA HAS INCREASED
SUBSTANTIALLY OVER THE PAST
DECADE. IF THE SUNSET IS NOT
EXTENDED, AS THE SENATOR SAID
THE FUNDS ALLOCATED FOR SAFE
PROGRAM WILL CEASE. FOR THESE
REASONS. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? PLEASE
COME FORWARD STATE YOUR NAME FOR
THE RECORD, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING, TAYLOR ROSIN ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA DAIRY'S INC AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. OTHER
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, SEEING NONE COME
FORWARD, SENATOR. UH, SENATOR
HAVE A LOT TO GO, PLEASE. CLOSE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. UM, I JUST
WANNA BE CLEAR THAT THIS BILL
MERELY EXTENDS THE TONNAGE TAX
ALREADY IN STATUTE FROM JANUARY
1ST 2025 THE JANUARY 1ST 2031
SENATE BILL 1367 DOES NOT
ESTABLISH A TAX A NEW TAX ON THE
INDUSTRY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN I VOTE. THANK YOU WITH
THAT WE'LL BRING IT TO THE
COMMITTEE. OR QUESTIONS OR A
MOTION. ALL RIGHT. THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED. THANK YOU. MOTION IS
DUE PASS. PLEASE CALL THE ROOM.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS. BUT
FIRST WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS
PADILLA PAD I, GROVE ALVARADO,
GIL HØI ALVARADO DEAL I CORTESI.
HURTADO OR CURTESY. I HURTADO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THERE. ON
CALL. SO.
AND THEN WE'LL PICK UP THE
SECOND BUILD. THAT'S ON CALL.
AND WE'LL OPEN IT UP. ALL RIGHT.
THE COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE
WILL RECONVENE AND AT THIS POINT
WHAT WE WILL DO IS ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO RECONSIDER AND OPEN
THE ROLE ON ON THE MATTER OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION WITH THAT
OBJECTION WILL RECONSIDER AN
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON MOVING
CONSENT. THE MOTION IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM ONE
S¼, B, 117 AND FILE ITEM TWO. S¼
B 1186 SENATORS PADILLA PADILLA,
I, GROVE GROVE I ALVARADO GIL
ALVARADO GILL I, CORTEZ CORTEZ.
I HURTADO THANK YOU. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS ARE REMOVED. IT'S
OUT WITH FOUR VOTES. FOUR VOTES
HIGH NÓ VOTES AGAINST THAT
LEAVES, UH, WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ON S¼ B 1367 HURTADO. FILE ITEM
THREE S¼ B 1367. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST REFER, REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS THREE, UH,
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING. I
SENATORS GROWTH GROVE I HURTADO.
SO FOR THAT BILL IS OUT FOR OH,
WITH THAT NOT BEING ANY FURTHER
BUSINESS OF THE COMMITTEE, THE
COMMITTEE WILL STAND AND
ADJOURNMENT. YOU. THANKS. SORRY
ABOUT THAT. SHANNON.